ça va cyril très bien depuis tant
d'années depuis tant d'années qu'on
s'est vus et oui rien fait alors vous
allez 41 ans vous êtes fils de l'éditeur
d'art jacques putman honte route
protecteur de bram van velde il de la
décoratrice andrée putman que tout le
monde connaît qui est mondialement connu
voilà vous êtes agent d'artistes est
désormais écrivain puisque vous publié
chez robert laffont
un livre qui s'appelle première pression
à froid sous titrée pur produit pinc
voilà alors c'est l'autobiographie d'un
des premiers peintres français sur moi
j'étais témoin vous étiez effectivement
l'un des premiers vins français en 77 et
une photo dans libération qu'il atteste
donc vous aviez 15 ans à cette époque à
et et c'est là qu'on s'est connu
d'ailleurs en 77 voilà alors vous
raconter votre vie vous raconter votre
expérience que sont devenus les parcs
parce qu'évidemment les mecs qui n'avait
no future qu'est ce qu'ils sont devenus
qu'elle a essayé mort reste presque en
grande part des prêts qu'elle a été le
futur des no futur voilà la question
pensent qu'il ya beaucoup de casse
beaucoup beaucoup de casse et vous vous
n'êtes pas passés loin de deux lacs de
la casse aussi ouais on est heureux de
vous voir
alors vous raconter votre vie votre vie
de famille alors au début ça commence
très bien c'est une ancienne usine
immense rue des grands augustins à paris
avec un appartement qui se raccorde à
lui l usine désaffectée donc c'est vrai
que tout ça est assez est assez
grandiose des amis de vos parents
setting lycées niki de saint phalle
sellette chinsky et puis la rue aussi
parce que c'est vrai que vous jouez dans
la rue devant chez vous avec les avec
les voisins voilà alors ça c'est
l'époque donc cela très bien avec vos
parents rue des grands augustins famille
bourgeoise branché dans l'art etc
et puis vous brancher mon cher cyril sur
la face obscure du rock'n'roll
c'est à dire à 9 ans il va voir les
stones au palais des sports est
évidemment dans les stones ce qu'il
préfère c'est sympathy for the devil tu
vois c'est à dire tout de suite il est
très attiré quand même ma part le côté
noir de cette musique
et quand le pain qui arrive vous adhérez
immédiatement à 7 à cette philosophie du
new futur devenait complètement destroy
et vos idoles là c'est plus les stones
c'est les sex pistols et encore mieux
les clashs voilà tout tout à fait alors
là vous avez les cheveux bleus moi je
m'en souviens
bleu et rouge bleu un voyage à londres
vous permet d'acheter le fameux blouson
streep et les voilà les gens de sangles
et le pantalon de vivienne westwood qui
avait pas mal marqué à l'époque
au total on est classé sangles et oui la
panoplie du pain
voilà était devenu parrain complètement
et alors le style de vie c'est-à-dire la
bière beaucoup beaucoup de bière de
laval star verte aller voilà tout à fait
le frein ganor locataire et ne fera que
je conseille à personne et ses bijoux se
limer les dents parce que soient les
grandes dents de lapin se fringuer nord
ça je vais te dire je crois qu'ils en
jeu je crois que le fond je crois que
cheryl cole chang adore ça a été
supprimé ah bon oui je pense que ça a
été supprimée parce que les autorités
médicales se sont aperçus que c'était
plus un indice de l'emploi est le bouc
ou le principe du pogo vous le savez on
saute on saute sur place en essayant de
cracher sur ses amis c'est comme le
héros castries dans le showbiz
mais c'est ça oui bien sûr virus aux
caisses des bouteilles de verre avant
par terre un petit tapis pour recycler
en quelqu'un tomberait bon alors là
alors cyril s'il était vraiment le pain
type on peut le dire un très disciplinés
on faisait tout ce qu'il fallait faire
pour être un vrai punk et la
consécration est arrivé lorsque cyril
piquemal a été interviewé par alain
pacadis dans libération évidemment ça a
été une espèce de d'apothéose est il
alors ce qui est extraordinaire c'est
l'histoire c'est qu'au départ le pain
que c'est une réaction contre les babas
contre les babas planant qui prenaient
des pétards qui avait les cheveux longs
qui étaient habillés avec des chemises
indienne qui écoute et calme
voilà c'est ça c'est ici d'un truc
contre l'hérault contre laplane reekoye
qu'est-ce qui est très bizarre c'est que
les pins qui au départ était en réaction
contre ça finalement son raid dans
sombré corps et âme dans la dope et
grave en tous les cas en ce qui vous
concerne pas là alors ce qui est très
bizarre c'est que c'est des amis de
votre mère qui vous ont fait prendre
votre première ligne d'héroïne
voilà tout est fait ça s'est fait un peu
par hasard j'ai été cueilli un peu à
froid sévit qu'elles achètent j'avais 15
ans et donc cette fête on ma
donné on mate fait hara et dayraut et on
a été même un peu plus loin c'est ce qui
est assez [ __ ] c'est qu'on m'a donnée
en même temps 3 grammes ce qui fait que
ça m'a permis d'être bien accro bout de
dix quinze jours ce qui fait que j'ai
été tout de suite c'était des vrais amis
de votre mère well et si je puis dire
oui si on peut dire est ce que vous les
avez revu depuis
à vrai dire ils sont morts les deux donc
ils s'en sortent bien d'une morale quand
le moral dans la vie quand on vous dit
ça a été sublime
évidemment si c'était infecte ça se
saurait et le problème serait réglé
voilà c'est vrai que séguéla et sa pub
en dix ans la drogue c'est de la merde
jamais vu personne a acheté 12 s'emballe
un gramme de merde et qu' il faut dire
que la drogue c'est de la merde mais
mais pas tout de suite c'est après alors
le leak effectivement c'est que donc il
vous donne ses 3 g et puis quand le
paquet est finie et ben vous êtes en
manque vous découvrez le manque
voilà le les reins commencent à bloquer
un peu et là ça devient en fait l enfer
alors ce qui est très bizarre avec le
monde sait qu'à l'époque où quand on
parlait du monde personnes comprenait et
puis maintenant tous les français
essaient d'arrêter de fumer pas tous à
beaucoup et quand j'ai vu à la télé une
pub tout à l'heure ah bah oui quand vous
sent tellement que mettez vous un patch
c'est à dire que ce moment qui était
réservé aux vrais gros gain attendu est
devenu complètement popularisé
maintenant les gens sont en manque de
nicotine comme vous avez été donc à ce
moment-là en manque d'héroïne alors mal
au dôme alors un moral à zéro vous
découvrez ce que c'est d'être accro aux
sacs au départ comme j'ai dis tout le
temps on en prend pour être bien et puis
après on en prend pour pas être mal et
donc vous essayer d'en trouver pour pas
être mal ça peut être normal tu prennes
de l'hérault c'est qu'à prendre on prend
juste pour être normal sinon ça sert
plus à rien voilà c'est pour ça que très
souvent les parents de deux jeunes
trouvent que leurs enfants ont l'air en
superforme parties sont défoncés il les
trouve assez pâlichon quand ils sont en
entrée parce que ils comprennent pas
alors votre père justement c'est
l'attitude des parents 68 c'est terrible
à dire mais enfin c'est vrai que c'est
terrible à dire mais c'est vrai c'est
vrai que votre père il vous filmer le
bal par jour il demande même pas où est
ce que vous cramer ce pognon en quoi
c'est pas pour nommer de marque mais il
n'y avait pas de y avait pas de voitures
de sport allemande décapotable dans la
cour c'est un mètre 93 je faisais 52 kg
donc ouais y avait quand même un
problème quoi donc le père lui vous
filmer le bal sans demander où ça va et
votre mère andrée basse moment là est
très préoccupée par sa survie aussi et
tout vous laisse un petit peu voilà
allez à aller à vau l'eau
et ça c'est un truc qu'on peut dire aux
parents qui nous regarde parce que il
faut quand même surveiller quoi c'est
vrai qu'un môme qui prend un gran d
euros tous les deux jours ça peut se
voir bout d'un moment juste marrant
c'est que vous n'avez jamais fumé des
joints
non vous êtes directement dans l'héroïne
êtes passés directement on dit souvent
les drogues douces amène aux drogues
dures vous êtes passé directement de
rigueur tout à fait voilà mais on
n'amène pas forcément un gros merci
aussi à tous les cas vous dites j'ai eu
comme destin l'héroïne comme d'autres
ont comme destin de star écrasé par un
bus il faisait comme si j'avais été
cueilli un peu à froid sens d'une
volonté farouche
j'ai pas été airs et alphabet city à en
trouver ques est arrivé à livrer à
domicile ça vous est déjà arrivé ça
stéphane non non j'ai pas eu cette
chance
tant mieux pour vous daguin tatoueur
c'est un ami de ses parents qui étaient
à tous je souhaite à chacun ses traits
vous pas si ça vous est arrivé ça non
non j'ai on a toujours fui
s'il part à contrôler en titre a concédé
ya prescription
on a vu beaucoup de gens tomber ouais
tombé à avoir des mauvaises et enfin
sortir d'une bonne situation et se
retrouver au plus bas que terre avec ça
donc ça nous a toujours fait peur alors
voilà alors la syrie de poupon dan quoi
alors gare du mans de mémoire mettez pas
de genre toi
rêva détrompe toi pourquoi tu crois je
me suis lancée dans la musique pour
tirer sur tout ce qui bouge est drogué
et voilà donc là c'est l'apothéose vous
partez à londres avec le fameux alain
pacadis quinze jours sans manger sans
dormir je comment vous avez un
rétrécissement de l'estomac cercle à un
moment encore m
à un moment vous mangez un petit morceau
de pain brioché vous avez l'impression
de bouffer un ours un coup voilà alors
bon je passe les galères ctc est
épouvantable et et un jour vous avec
votre mère aux états unis et vous allez
voir si ce virus
d comme je l'avais rencontré side à
londres à l'époque deux ans soit singles
à l'époque de mclaren quand ma mère a
voulu m'emmener à new york
quand j'avais 15 ans je lui ai dit moi
je veux bien y aller mais à la condition
c'est qu'on aille voir s'il en prison
comme j'étais mineure il y avait eu que
ma mère ma compagne au pénitencier au
pénitencier américain
si vous venez voir rien c'est que j'ai
déjà vous même pas très très bien
on est un petit pays un des courants et
en civil suscité au pénitencier parce
qu'il avait tué sa petite amie donc
l'arrêter à le chelsea dans le célèbre
dans la légende noire du rock'n'roll et
là quand vous le voyez quand même c'est
ce vrai dayraut plus de déguisements
vous dites dans votre bouquin no more
chaud ouais c'est le petit oiseau
mouillé c'est l'arrogance a disparu il
dans sa petite tenue orange avec les
gens va tâcher et tout et on se parle
par téléphone il ya une vitre c'est vrai
que c'était - the great rock'n'roll
swindle c'est clair c'est clair il est
mou en costume maintenant il est entendu
il est mort d'une overdose quelques
jours avant son procès sylvie cious sa
mère qui était à moitié folle et à
moitié zhang
dès que les dés que malcom mclaren a
payé la caution
pourrait faire sortir le lendemain sa
mère lui a trouvé un plan voix
semblablement d'assez bonnes vu qu'il
est mort deux heures après comme sa
grande famille vous raconter toute
l'histoire quoi les dealers le rapport
sado maso avec les dealers qui vous font
attendre
vous allez chez eux puis vous faut leur
parler de leur famille parce que je n'ai
qui tarde quand même à sortir le petit
paquet le ticket pas et donc vous êtes
là vous raconter tout ça très bien il ya
une anecdote qui est très vrai plus
votre bouquin est très vrai vous dites
que vous éventré les pailles avec un
cutter après huit jours d'utilisation
pour récupérer le dépôt d'une semaine de
consommation tout ça c'est très c'est un
truc de diamètre est assez parlant c'est
assez parlant pour ceux qui connaissent
malheureusement voilà vous raconter
comment l'hérault vous prend la tête
toute la journée commença devient
travail à temps complet calcium full
time job ouais c'est ça ouais staff du
matin rue soir vous cherchez vous
trouvez vous prenez vous cherchez le
trouve les trouver le plan ainsi de
suite voilà alors vous auriez pu y
rester et vous raconter comment un jour
devant un hôtel à bangkok est un mec qui
vend des souvenirs avec marc et lov
bangkok un petit 1 petite taille et qui
vous dit c'est vrai en même temps et bus
stop pourquoi tu fais ça quoi tu n'étais
pas venu me dit c'est un hymne dit une
phrase très bizarres et me dit c'est pas
pour toi alors qu'on est à bangkok
en face d'un hôtel de junk assez aigu
que lui la mini
sa mini échoppes qui est là et je vais
le voir comme ça pour parler avec lui
puis au bout de deux jours on commence
un peu à sympathiser il me dit tu sais
moi des blancs qui finissent 25 ans dans
les geôles thaïlandaises j'en ai vu
partir beaucoup c'est pas pour toi mais
par contre je connais une pilule magique
parce que
je sais absolument pas ce que c'était il
se trouve que c'était de la méthadone la
fameuse dada et c'était très en avance
de la suivante elle donne en france et
donc c'est comme ça grâce à la méthadone
grâce à ce petit vendeur de souvenirs à
bangkok vous découvrez la méthadone et
puis après vous vous arrangez votre
affaire vous faites vous vos posologie
vous même pour vous en sortirez vous
vous en est de sortir mais la sphère a
quand même duré douze ans mais ça c'est
12 ans dans l'hérault c'est long c'est
assez long très très long
c'est très très long parce que c'est
très très con donc les choses très très
con guignard 12 ans est forcément très
très long si vous dites ce qui ne vous
tue pas vous rend plus fort c'est vrai
ouais c'est la fameuse phrase de niche
va quand même temps il vaut mieux pas
passer par là sur plus viscéral c'est
parce qu'on doit dire aux enfants pour
démarrer le 10 la conversation en
musique les jeunes comme les adultes qui
vous disais que c'était pas bien qui
avait pas en prendre ça vous a pas
empêché de même temps les héros de ces
années là était pas du tout les rois
d'aujourd'hui c'est à dire que c'était
l'hérault était beaucoup plus chic
c'était avait un côté au coeur des
années 20 voilà tout à fait c'était que
de la taille blanche labro lebron ça a
été un choc
une étoile à dire aujourd'hui qui
seraient tentés par sa sé on répète
fatalement les mêmes conneries il faut
les respecter parce qu'un encore quand
envie d'en prendre
il faut l'hérault c'est vraiment
l'horreur quoi c'est un cauchemar on a
quand même tous été témoins de plein
d'amis 1 qui sont plus là pour nous
raconter ça donc
et puis je pense que ça correspond plus
du tout à l'époque dans lequel on vit à
un côté complètement out quoi dans
l'hérault il ya un truc pas tes bons
arguments c'est à dire que c'est plus
branché voilà peut-être dépassé il ya
des trucs mieux maintenant ça va mais
quand tu vois là là là il ya quand même
une traîtrise à ce niveau là tout tout
les pop stars qui ceux qui s'en
mettaient plein le corner quand on
revoit david bowie maintenant qui fait
de la pub pour vittel pour pisser tu
vois ça fait un peu alors moi justement
j'ai essayé de ne pas tomber dans le
truc qui passe de l'extrême de l'hérault
à la soupe aux poireaux yoga parce que
c'est une autre forme j'ai aussi grave
végétarienne et ces mêmes principes je
t'arrête et obtenir en temps avec un bon
bordeaux
voilà très bien on est heureux de vous
voir si elle les corrections de nourrir
as they do in a l'habitude
abonnez vous mettez un pouce bleus